nice look at that  alright the new hoodies came in there's  Nina there Stephanie there's Hayden  rocking the new shirts there's a plane  on the front there's mine look a nice  look at that Nina is actually wearing me  with the child sighs child large so  these are not available for public  consumption yet it's a private order but  they're also coming for a few of you  loyal youtubers YouTube fans have been  leaving a lot of comments I know I  connected to announce for your size  either the hoodies or tissues are on  their way to you soon so I hope you guys  enjoy make a video when you get them I'd  love to see them on you and that's it  have a great weekend